the prospect of artificial intelligence
excites and repulses people in equal
measure will it bring us a kind of
paradise or a techno hell to get a
clearer handle of what might happen and
when it's best to divide AI into three
categories the first of these is
artificial narrow intelligence or what
people call weak AI this kind of AI is
already in place it's the kind of AI
that uses big data and complex
algorithms to arrange your facebook
timeline or beat you at chess narrow AI
has an intelligence that's limited to
one very specific arena it may not be
able to pass the Turing test but our
lives infrastructure and financial
markets are already very dependent on it
the next step up the AI ladder is
artificial general intelligence or
strong AI this is an intelligence that
can at last think as well as we can
we're probably about 30 years away from
this the hurdles to creating strong AI
are all about building machines that are
going to be good at doing things which
come very easily to humans but which
machines have traditionally really
stumbled with oddly it's so much easier
to build a machine that can do advanced
calculus than it is to build one that
can get milk from the fridge recognizer
granny or walk up the stairs
our brains are brilliant at so-called
everyday tasks like decoding 3d images
working out people's motivations and
spotting casual sarcasm with very far
ahead of machines here some scientists
doubt we'll ever see strong AI but the
majority of AI experts alive today seem
to think that will be there in the
coming decades
if you're under 35 the great probability
is that you will be there to enter the
strong AI age so what will happen to the
world once we've succeeded in creating
an intelligence to rival or equal our
own well the rivalry will be extremely
short-lived for one thing because the
key point about strong AI is that it
will be able to learn and upgrade itself
on its own without instructions this is
what makes it so revolutionary and so
different to almost any machine we've
ever been
the maker won't be in charge of mapping
out all the possibilities of the thing
he or she has made the machine will be
given a baseline capacity but it can
then build on this as it develops it
will be a trial-and-error learner with
an infinite capacity to acquire skills
it'll have what ai professionals call
recursive self-improvement this is
crucial because it means there'll be no
reason for AI to stall once it reaches
the human level the more intelligent
system becomes the better it becomes at
improving itself so the more it will
learn and do this virtuous cycle equates
to an exponential growth in intelligence
that would leave humanity amazed but
also baffled dwarfed and perhaps very
scared it might not take very long at
all only months perhaps before the
machine is cleverer than its creator
this is the moment that gets very
exciting it's a moment often referred to
as the singularity which is where we
encounter the third sort of AI
artificial super intelligence
technically this is any AI that exceeds
human levels of intelligence even
slightly but any self improving super
intelligence is going to be sure to
improve a lot very fast indeed
AI that reached this level would soon be
leagues ahead of us and statements such
as well let's just switch it off might
be like trying to take down the internet
with a slingshot the prospect of such
super intelligence appalls and excites
people in equal measure we're
approaching two alternative futures with
the speed and uncertainty of a skydiver
who can't quite remember if he's wearing
a parachute or a rucksack some including
Bill Gates Stephen Hawking an L on musk
are so scared they believe that we're
unlikely ever to be able to effectively
control any super intelligence we create
artificial minds we'll just
single-mindedly pursue their aims and
these aims may not necessarily coincide
with ours
a machine wouldn't specifically want to
kill us but it's a morality would mean
that it would be willing to cause our
extinction if necessary these critics
point out that intelligence is not value
loaded it's tempting to assume that
anything intelligent will just naturally
develop vaguely human values like
empathy in a respect for life but this
can't be guaranteed
because ethical values are based on
purely human axioms and given that we
find it impossible to agree among
ourselves what's right and wrong
in areas like euthanasia or abortion say
how could we possibly program a computer
with a knowledge that could soundly and
reliably be deemed moral now that's a
pessimistic angle but there is a more
cheerful angle of course according to
the optimists in a world artificial
superintelligence machines will still be
our servants we'll give them some basic
rules about never killing or doing us
any harm and then they'll set about
solving all the things that have long
been deviled us the immediate priority
of super intelligence would be to help
us to create free energy in turn
dramatically reducing the prices for
almost everything we would soon be in
the era that Google's chief futurologist
reycarts file describes as abundance
everything currently costly would drop
to almost zero the way that data costs
now work for money would essentially
come to an end
the real challenge would be not getting
miserable with all this abundance after
all Palm Springs and Montecarlo already
now point to some of the dangers of
wealthy people with nothing much to do
the solution here is to develop a side
of AI that's been intriguingly dubbed a
e AI or artificial emotional
intelligence this a e AI would help us
with all the tricky tasks at the
emotional psychological and
philosophical end of things we'd be
helped with understanding our psyches
mastering our emotions drawing out our
true talents we'd hear what we were best
suited to do with our lives and guiding
us to the people with whom we might form
good and satisfying relationships most
of the many psychological mistakes which
allow us to waste our lives could be
averted instead of fumbling through a
mental fog of insecurities and
inconsistencies we'd be guided to a more
compassionate happier and wiser future
science fiction is sometimes dismissed
in elite circles but we can see now that
thinking twenty to fifty years ahead and
imagining how life will be is a central
task for all of us we should all be
science fiction writers of a kind in our
minds we are poised just before a
tipping point in human history we need
to build up the wisdom to control which
way we will tip and part of that means
thinking very realistically about things
that today still seem rather fine
as mag Oracle humans are tool-making
animals were on the brink of creating
tools like no others so the trick is
going to be to stay close to the
underlying ancient purpose of every tool
which is to help us to do something we
actually want to do more effectively if
we keep our wits about us there's no
real reason our computers should
necessarily run away from us they should
just be much much better versions of our
earliest flint axes
you